Speaker 1: Welcome back to the David Pakman
show. I am Farron Cousins from Ring of Fire
sitting in for David Pakman this week. And
if you've enjoyed me, feel free. Please
subscribe to the Ring of Fire podcast. Go
to our O.f podcast, dot com and subscribe
to our YouTube channel at youtube.com. The Ring
of Fire or YouTube.com slash fair and balanced.
Let's get right back into the news. We've got
a lot of Republican infighting and of course,
some more news from the Jan. six select committee.
So let's jump in first and foremost, Steve Bannon.
Steve Bannon is unhappy with Mitch McConnell
because Donald Trump is unhappy with Mitch
McConnell. As we all know, Donald Trump has
been engaged in a months long battle with Mitch
McConnell that has kind of had some highs and
some lows, and Trump trying out his new nickname
for him the old Broken Crow, the Old Crow, the
broken old crow. A lot of different iterations.
He hasn't quite settled on one yet, but either
way, he's mad at Mitch McConnell, and of course,
he is encouraging Republicans to oust him from his
leadership position. So this past Friday on his
war room show, Steve Bannon joined in and attacked
Mitch McConnell for what he sees as a betrayal
of Donald Trump. Here's what Bannon said.
He is a direct challenge to President Trump,
and Trump is trying to lead this country through
these horrible times. Mitch McConnell That dirt
bag right there gave the Biden regime two
and a half trillion to fund their madness.
Their madness. These are horrible times,
he says. And we're funding madness, huh?
You know what really gets me about that before
I get into the really the heart of the argument
here is what the hell are they talking about?
Horrible times like what exactly are conservatives
so mad about right now other than losing the 2020
election? What about their lives has changed since
Joe Biden came along? We haven't had lockdowns.
We have vaccines readily available, we're on the
verge of approving an actual COVID treatment.
So you can't complain about the COVID stuff.
He hasn't changed your taxes, so you can't
complain about that. So what exactly?
Are conservatives angry about with the
Biden administration, honest to God,
I want an answer to that. I want a real,
legitimate answer. From conservatives about what
you're so mad about from this administration, and
I think that is a question we should be asking of
them on a regular basis. Why are you mad? What
has he done that makes these horrible times?
Conversation for another day, though, right,
folks, let's get back to what Steve Bannon said.
He's betrayed Donald Trump, he said.
And this is because, of course, they. Worked a
deal out McConnell and Chuck Schumer to allow
for the debt ceiling to be raised. That's what
that's the heart of all of this. At least Steve
Bannon's gripe. So we got a higher debt ceiling,
right? So the U.S. doesn't default on their debt.
And according to Bannon, that's a betrayal
of Trump. A betrayal of Trump. You know, the
old retired guy who's sitting down there in
Florida playing golf, he has been betrayed.
He's not in power, Steve. So I don't know exactly
what you're so mad about betraying Donald Trump.
Because the man doesn't have a
job, he's he's retiring. But again,
Mitch McConnell, Donald Trump and now, of
course, Steve Bannon been in this feud.
Trump is trying to back Republicans for Senate.
Two of them have pledged, If I get in the office,
I'm going to kick McConnell out of his leadership
position. Trump is encouraging other Republicans
to do it, and so far, not a single sitting
Republican has signed on to this idea
of kicking Mitch McConnell out of his leadership
position. Let me explain why, but to explain why,
I got to read a little bit more about what
Bannon said here. Here's what your legacy
will be. People are going to throw up in their
mouth. You have betrayed the Republican Party.
You've betrayed the movement. You're only there
because of Trump. You never had any loyalty.
The man. Who's been representing the people
of Kentucky in the United States Senate
since I was two years old? So
since the 1980s, the early 1980s.
He's only there because of Trump. Steve. No,
you've spent a lot of dumb things in your life,
and that might actually be one of the dumbest.
Mitch McConnell doesn't owe any of his success
and let's be honest, it has been a success for
him to Donald Trump. Like, literally none of it.
Mitch McConnell's legacy is not going to be people
throwing open their mouths unless, of course,
they're on the left because his legacy is packing
the courts with these corporate, his judges.
His legacy is tax cuts for the wealthy. His
legacy is obstructing any kind of forward
progress for the United States of America. None
of which he owes to Donald Trump. He did it under
Reagan. He did it under H.W. Bush. He did it
under George W. Bush. It wouldn't matter who
the Republican president was, Mitch McConnell was
one of the guys calling the shots the entire time.
And when he had Democratic Presidents Clinton,
Obama and now Biden, he's been leading the charge
for obstruction. None of which again, he owes to
Donald Trump. So, Bannon, you're delusional if you
think that Mitch McConnell owes anything to Donald
Trump, if anything, it's the other way around.
Mitch McConnell's good at politics, and I will
give him credit for that. He is a horrible person,
in my opinion, who is enacted some horrible
policies and blocked some great ones.
But when it comes to being a Republican who knows
how to do things, Mitch McConnell, there's no
one better than him. And that is literally the
only praise I will ever get for Mitch McConnell